In this video, I'll show you how to install
RStudio, which is a graphical interface for programming with
the R language. Simply open up any web browser and
go to RStudio.com then you want to go to download now.
You are going to run RStudio from your desktop so
click on this link. Now here's where I want you
to be very careful. RStudio requires R first, so
if you don't already have the programming language R installed,
you need to download it here. Now this is a really easy link to
miss so make sure you click here first to install R, before installing RStudio.
Once you're at cran.rstudio.com, you want to select
the download for the Mac OSX version. This
will bring up another page and then you can download the latest version of R.
It may take some time to download so you might
want to take a break and then come back to the
computer. Once you've opened up the package, follow the instructions for
installing R. You should end up getting a successful message for
the installation. Now you're ready to go and install RStudio.
The website will recommend the best version of RStudio for
you so just click on whatever one comes up for you
first. Once you've downloaded this, you want to open that package. Now,
just drag RStudio into your applications and you'll be good to go.